heureux qui comme ulysse a fait un beau
voyage les élèves de 3e du collège de la
montagne se sont rendus en bretagne sur
les traces de ceux qui ont peuplé l'île
de la réunion
il faut savoir que parmi les premiers
marins qui ont posé le pied sur notre
île figurait un breton un voyage qui a
débuté de la citadelle de port-louis
situé dans la rade de lorient
c'est donc en bateau que se fait la
traversée est à del et ses remparts
classés monument historique abrite deux
musées et c'est celui de la compagnie
des indes qui retient plus précisément
l'intérêt de l'épopée du peuplement de
notre île puisque c'est d'ici que tout
est parti
la compagnie des indes c'est en effet
une une entreprise qui fait du commerce
avec on va dire avec le monde entier
c'est vrai qu'on va l'appeler la
compagnie des indes
parce qu'on va concentrer une bonne
partie des activités
ici en asie on l'a sur le sur la carte
qui se situe juste là une partie de de
l'un des deux parents de l'asie en tout
cas l'extraordinaire histoire des
grandes compagnies de commerce des xviie
et xviiie siècles avait pour but d'aller
à la recherche de marchandises dans les
terres aussi lointaine que les rives de
l'afrique l'orient l'asie des chemins
qui passait forcément par l'océan indien
il ya le quantité de produits venus
avant en asie et ses produits de luxe
peuvent être vos du cher en europe qui
vous intéresser des gens assez riche de
l'aristocratie à c'est un jeune très
riche de l'aristocratie en europe cette
entreprise gigantesque qui a permis les
échanges de marchandises nous renvoie
l'océan indien et à l'île de la réunion
après avoir expliqué l'organisation des
échanges et les conditions de la
traversée des océans mais les collégiens
des couples à celles qui traitent des
mascagnes les îles des mascareignes dans
l'auto de la compagnie des indes donc ça
veut dire à partir pour le coup de dés
années 1720 et bien c'est une escale
pour la france ce sont des îles qui vont
être investis par la france au début du
xviiie siècle après le départ des
portugais puis des hollandais ce sont
des îles vierges
elles sont très intéressantes pour eux
pour les français pour ses escales parce
qu'il y a des notamment l'île maurice
il y a des
l'irak bien abrité des espaces bien
arrêtée pour pouvoir mettre des bateaux
et puis il ya de l'eau sur ces îles et
avoir de l'eau sur ces il est vital pour
ces bateaux qui ont déjà fait quatre
mois cinq mois en mer l'île de la
réunion mais également l'île maurice
avec la tragique histoire d'amour de
paul et virginie
le musée de la compagnie des indes fait
aussi référence à la faune et à la flore
qui entoure nos zyl maquettes de
vaisseaux estampes carte l'ancien
mobilier indo-européen porcelaine de
chine cotonnade indiennes sont autant de
témoignages de cette incroyable aventure
maritime lis très impressionnant parce
que c'est dur de faire tout ce voyage
prendre plusieurs mois pour arriver deux
en france à la réunion et ben bella pont
des objets de loi et des esclaves
ici il y avait à breton et 10,9 malgache
est lâché à la réunion faire
mais à la réunion qu'on faisait des
trajets pour vendre des produits des
objets et quelques esclaves qu on peut
aussi conquérir quelques pays
c'est ce que tu as trouvé ça intéressant
ça existe et est fascinant vous êtes
intéressé au musée dans lequel nous
sommes est à avoir avec qui j'ai eu un
réel échange et je vous remercie pour ça
parce que les petits français qui a la
possibilité pour revenir au musée tous
les quarts d'heure parce qu'ils habitent
juste à côté se comportent n'importe
comment
alors je vous assure vous avez vous dit
un seul viser mieux comprendre d'où tout
est parti c'est aussi mieux comprendre
vers quoi aller avec ce retour sur les
terres du peuplement
chacun comprend un peu mieux ce
métissage qui caractérise les habitants
qui vivent sur l'île de la réunion
carly ya deux siècles ce sont en effet
des hommes venus de toutes les contrées
qui ont construit notre île